I'm so happy to talk to you Patton god
bless you yeah this is trust me this
interview has been a lifeline for me
this has been like holding concert
tickets I've known about it for a couple
of weeks and it's like if I can just get
to Tuesday morning and talk to Conan
this is no sir I was I was coming to the
theater today to tape this and I was
thinking oh great I'm so starved to talk
to funny people and you're one of my
favorite people and I was like I get to
talk to Patton today and so I I think I
drove 80 miles an hour to get to the
theater just so we could have this
interview let's make this about you and
then more about me yes how are you doing
how are you doing during isolation are
you handling this all right and why are
you sitting in a Lowe's theater right
now look when the shelter-in-place order
came down you know I was I was in an
early screening of Black Widow no
spoilers but you know I'm just I've been
in place and you can live on red vines
and sprite people don't understand this
but it's a diet so you've been sitting
that they they shouted Kovac quarantined
while the movie was ending and you just
said I'll just stay here I go yeah this
is this the next phase of the Marvel
movies where they actually you know add
some kind of outside threat oh no it's
really real and you know I'm kind of the
last one left here a lot of us have gone
insane there's one other guy but he is
living under the seats now so it's just
I'm kind of the spokesman it's they said
you you will speak for all of us here
and in the theater I've been handling
things okay I realize the other day that
a lot of times in the morning I will go
sit on my front porch we have like a
front porch swing and I'll sit out there
and read a book and the same people will
go walking by and I'm starting to worry
that I'm becoming the weird fixture in
the neighborhood the guy in his robe and
cargo shorts just kind of waving at
people with a book and they they use me
as a oh it's well it's 9:00 a.m. he's
out there like I'm the weird
neighborhood clock now things buy but
I've become a guy who sits
his front porch and waves of people
right right yes the thing you as a child
or as a teenager you thought I'll never
be that guy ever yes dick oh my god I'm
the guy no I am I'm the guy in like the
slasher movie at the beginning who's
like that house has a death curse yes
you're that guy you know what I'm
missing now a hair and makeup team I am
missing a hair and makeup team when okay
first off your hair they should take
they should use time-lapse photos that
should be the chronicle of this
quarantine is Conan's air like the
ongoing like the bigger and bigger it
gets
when this quarantine ends every actor
and actress we should organize some
massive dinner celebration parade just
for hair and makeup people they should
they should be whenever we see them we
should like avert our gaze and kneel
like that yes yes they are so clearly
such be there beyond crucial in in show
business I mean we knew that they were
valuable but my god the next whatever
the next live Academy Award should be
there should be they should like have a
nation they bring it powder puff out on
stage we should all like stand and just
kind of worship it just like each
signing thing right oh my god hair and
makeup people I've always tried to be
nice to you but I was not being nice
enough I promise you this is oh I wish
I'm gonna show up in that trailer every
day with muffins and coffee just thank
you I've been frightening people online
with my hair every day on the show
because every day like some days I kind
of comb it up a little bit but it's
gotten so long Jesus there's like 9 feet
of hair and then it turns into this
tsunami but then if I let it go it comes
down and I sort of look like you know
hey man and ya playin my song man
and I'm pushing my hair back this way
and yeah it's a but I'm just sort of
enjoying letting it all go just let it
all go
yeah if you if you didn't have any
product in your hair right now you would
look like the one Viking on the raid
that like knows what all that like the
codes and code X's me like there's the
big brawny guys you're like legs no this
means there be dragons listen to like
you're the guy they bring along wait a
minute so I'm not the good fighter or
the strong Viking I'm the guy that's
like no they bring you along to
translate like Lich they make sure they
don't open any cursed items that's what
they bring a lot